[MUSIC PLAYING]
KENNETH FORD: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for
coming and watching
my session, which is going to
be Android on large screens.
So as we all know, Android has
evolved from just being a phone
platform.
It's available on
watches and cars,
as we just heard,
desktop, phones.
And specifically,
the mobile space
has also changed
pretty drastically.
Let's see what your mobile
APK is running on today.
So starting off
with the phone, it's
what we all develop for
mainly, if not solely.
A couple of keys
about the platform.
It's portrait first, touch
first, and full screen first.
A lot of apps now
even lock rotation.
Some users do obviously
use multi-window
or stylus and things like that.
But majority of your
users are using it
with regular touch screens
and in full screen.
Moving on to tablets.
Both orientations here are
kind of first class citizens.
If you do opt to portrait,
users can still use your app
in the portrait landscape.
Larger screens do bring
challenges design wise,
but also the ability to
kind of do different things,
take more advantage
of the real estate,
allow your users to
do things faster.
But more importantly,
the different medium
kind of brings a different
focus on what apps are probably
going to be used more heavily--
content apps or media
consumption apps,
productivity apps, things
that can really take
advantage of the larger screen.
And then moving on to kind
of the desktop platforms.
We have Chrome OS,
we have some OEMs
that have made desktop
platforms as well
like the Samsung [INAUDIBLE],,
the [INAUDIBLE] [? make ?]
desktop mode.
Also, Android has now
brought the ability
to really take advantage of
having external displays.
So it's very possible
that your app even if it's
running on a phone is
actually being displayed
to an external monitor.
This is really where the
biggest difference comes
in where it's landscape first.
All these environments have
some sort of window resizing,
and multi-windows could
be used a lot more often.
And you have new first
class input methods
such as keyboard and
mouse and track pads
that actually either
ship with the device
or will be connected.
So what's the focus
on when you're
thinking about kind of how
to bring your apps to all
these platforms and have
a good user experience?
Number one is design.
Again, if you've really
been focusing on phones,
most of your
designs are probably
very portrait based and kind
of smaller screen based.
Window management is
probably the biggest place
where we see issues
with partner's apps.
Dealing with resizing, some
multi-window consideration,
things like that are
just problems we've never
had to focus before.
And then we're going
to talk a little bit
about the tooling that's
available from Google
to make sure that you're
able to actually develop
for these platforms and bring
it into your actual cycle.
So talking about design.
Raise your hands if you have
layouts for large screens
or tablets at all.
That's a lot more
people than I expected.
Cool.
So biggest thing is just
thinking about larger screens,
again.
Probably for the
last couple of years,
we've seen a lot
more apps come out
that they may lock the
portrait or are solely mobile
focused, which makes sense.
But with the more and
more growing number
of platforms that are running
your mobile APK but showing
a completely different
form factor or platform,
it's time to start
thinking again
about how to really bring the
best experience to those areas.
A really bad example of design
is actually Google Play Music,
which is always great.
So a couple things about this
that really are not great
is super stretch layout.
There's tons of white
space that could
be used to show more
content to the user,
whether it's album descriptions,
artist descriptions, album
art, things like that.
The biggest key here though is
there's no line dividers, which
on a phone is fine because
the screen is so small,
you can see what options
menu you're clicking on.
When you take it to kind of
a larger landscape layout,
it's really hard to
actually follow the lines
and see what item you're
pressing options menu for.
An external partner that we
worked a lot with actually
is 1Password.
So looking at their
phone layouts,
it's kind of your
standard list of items
that you'll drill down into.
But when you move
to a larger screen,
they really take advantage
of the real estate going
to almost like a
three panel layout,
allowing the user to really
get whatever content they
need in a lot less
clicks and a lot faster.
Also being able to showcase more
information at the same time.
So kind of going back
to the same point
is, again, just building
layouts for both orientations.
And there's a couple
of big keys for this.
Again, not all platforms
are portrait first.
A lot of the desktop
environments--
if you're only really
building for portrait,
you're going to have a
pretty bad user experience
when I want to use your app
in, let's say, full screen,
or even just the top
half of the screen
if I'm trying to multitask.
On top of that,
resizing capabilities
allow the user to make
your app whatever size,
orientation, or screen ratio
that they really want to.
So you really want to let
the user really decide
how they want to use your app.
Going back to kind of
mainly the desktop platforms
is designing for input
mediums other than touch.
Make sure your design is taken
into consideration, like how
your app works maybe using a
mouse or stylus, and things
like that.
On top of this,
the UX patterns are
different for non-touch devices.
Things like right
clicking is a little bit
different than what we kind of
are used to with long pressing.
Most of the paradigms are long
pressing to multi-select items.
Whereas when you right
click on a desktop,
you're usually
expecting some type of
pop up context menu
and things like that.
So taking the time
to really think
about how your app works for
the different UX considerations.
The other big one that we
notice is hover actions.
On the web or on desktop
environments for the mouse,
you really expect
some type of feedback
when you move your mouse
over an action item
to let you know that
there is actually
something you can do
there, whether it's
clickable, or dragable.
There's some behavior,
there's some feedback.
Myself, even if I use the
app on a phone extensively--
Google Drive is a
good example of this--
when I use it on, let's
say, Android on Chrome OS,
I'll miss actions
that I can actually
do because just natively
on this platform,
I'm expecting some
type of hover actions.
I'm going to go over
two simple APIs.
There are many APIs
that kind of help
handle a lot of these
input methods and things,
such as mouse scrolling
and things like that.
And there'll be resources
when the slides get posted.
But right clicking, which is
one of the usual kind of feature
blocks, is super easy.
You just set an on
context with listener
and make sure that you're
exposing whatever behavior
or functionality you have on
long press in this method.
Again, also hopefully
considering any type of UX
changes you need to make.
And then setting the
hover listener to kind of
watch for the user's points.
You're hovering over the
item and [? out. ?] Again,
this is really
the biggest one we
see that will lead to
kind of misfunctionality
or kind of really give you
the desktop native feel,
or even just kind of the
large screen native feel.
In terms of hovering, most
of our native components
do handle this somewhat.
But depending on the
colors you're using,
the contrast and
change may not be
enough for you or your users,
or especially accessibility,
things like that.
At the end of the
day though, you
know how your users use the
app, and you know the product.
So take some time
and use your app
on kind of these
different platforms
and think about how you would
expect the app to behave,
things that you would expect
the app to take advantage of.
Note taking out
the stylus based--
may not really need to focus
much on mouse input or keyboard
input, where a
productivity app is really
going to want to take advantage
of all the screen real estate
and find ways to let
the users do what they
need to do as fast as possible.
So talking about
window management.
This, again, is really
the biggest area
where we see crashes happen
because it's just challenges
that we've never had
to face before and kind
of a mobile only environment.
I love harping on
rotation because I
see so many apps that
lock to portrait, which
is completely understandable.
But on these
different platforms,
it really shows kind of
where the experience falls.
If you do locked on portrait
on Chrome OS specifically,
this is how your
app will look like.
You'll get these super cool
black bars on the side.
And it's really
just a whole bunch
of wasted screen real estate.
On top of that, it also
really shows the user
and gives this really
non-native feel
just because it doesn't really
conform to the platform well.
Now, why do we generally
lock to portrait?
Usually to run away from
handling configuration
changes because
they've always been
rather difficult to deal with.
But on these larger
screen platforms,
configuration changes are
more important than ever.
Resizing and
multi-window brings a lot
of new kind of configuration
change paradigms
and challenges.
Chrome OS is probably
one of the most complex
of the resizing
strategies because it
does trigger configuration
changes pretty frequently.
I know some of the
other desktop platforms
don't cause as many
configuration changes.
On top of that,
with bigger screens,
multi-window is going
to be used much more
frequently than before.
So any bugs that
you do have in that
are going to start kind of
being surfaced a lot more.
This is a quick GIF
about just kind of how
resizing on Chrome OS works.
So anytime one of
those labels changes,
it's going through a complete
destroy and rebuild process.
So you can imagine that this
can get triggered substantially
faster and substantially
more often than on a phone
just because rotation
is just kind of slow.
Jetpack helps with this.
Things like view model
and being able to build
your own components that
are lifecycle aware really
allows you to kind of take
any of your business logic
that's in your
activity, anything
you're doing to save
state, and move it
there so that your activity
destroy and rebuild process
is really quick.
Your app will not
always be in focus.
Again, this isn't new.
With Android N, we
brought multi-window.
But on these larger
screens, you're
going to see this being
the case a lot more often.
I know most of us that
work with a large monitor
have multiple things up at once.
And you need to make
sure that your content is
still visible and playing even
if you're not the focused app.
So make sure that you're
still displaying messages
if you're a messaging app,
or your content is continuing
playing.
And then take advantage
of the features
on these new and
different platforms.
Larger screens and
external monitors
bring new possibilities.
One of the things that
we've seen a couple apps do,
such as email apps or
word processing apps
that really kind of bring
a better experience,
is allowing email composed
windows or new documents
to be shown in different tasks
so that the user can really
see their email plus
this new email they're
creating in a different window.
Something that we
released quite a bit ago
but is now really being used
a lot more is drag and drop.
Again, these desktop
platforms specifically,
users expect drag and
drop to be a thing.
They're not really
going to understand
that this is an Android app and
we've never thought about it
before, so why
doesn't this exist?
So think about if drag
and drop kind of makes
sense in your app, and how
you can kind of bring it
to these platforms.
And then not really
window management,
but different features that
are kind of new to some
of these ecosystems is just--
different info capabilities
and specifically increased
stylus usage.
The biggest thing
that we've seen
that users have logged
on some of the apps
that we've worked
with is the ability
to have keyboard shortcuts
and keyboard navigation
so that if they're
heavy power users
or there's things
that people do often,
they're able to do these things
faster in and out of the app,
get what they need to get
done as quick as possible.
So this is great and all,
but how do we actually
build for this?
And moving on to tooling.
It'd be awful if I came up here
and talked about kind of you
should do all these things,
yet there's no tools from us
to make this possible.
Most of the tooling
examples that we do
have are around Chrome OS.
A, it's our
platform, and then B,
it's also kind of the most all
in one platform that we have.
Most devices ship with a
keyboard and track pad.
Some don't even
have a touch screen.
And then it has one of the more
complex resizing strategies.
So it's kind of the best all
in one platform to test on.
We were working on bringing some
interest to the integration,
specifically around larger
screens in Chrome OS.
Lint additions are coming soon.
It's actually my job once this
event's over to finish this.
And then we're really
looking at more things
that we can bring to the IDE.
It's really great to have
devices that you can test on,
but we want to be able
to give quicker feedback
and things to look for
while you're actually
developing in the IDE.
So if you have ideas,
please come let me know.
There's a Chrome OS emulator
that's currently in preview.
So if you don't have devices,
you can download the emulator
and start to kind of see
where your app falls apart,
things that don't work,
things that crash, et cetera.
One of the biggest
complaints for developing
for Chrome OS in
testing has been
having to use ADB over Wi-Fi,
and the development cycle's
always been pretty crappy.
But on the HP Chromebook
X2 and the Pixelbook,
you can ADB over USB, so you
can actually bring the devices
into the same kind
of development cycle
that you do with phones.
Other devices still
require ADB over Wi-Fi,
but we hope to bring more and
more devices to this feature.
But the easiest
way really is just
to run Android
Studio on Chrome OS.
This is available currently
on the Pixelbook in preview,
and we're hoping to bring it
to more devices in the future.
And we do have this setup at
the Android and Chrome OS tables
as well as the
Android Studio table.
Being able to just
kind of build the app
and deploy it
directly to the device
makes the whole development
cycles substantially easier
and faster.
At the end of day, Android
is always evolving.
There's more and more platforms
that are running APKs,
whether they're different
flavors or even just
your mobile APK.
So make sure that
your app is too.
Thank you.
Again, please ask any questions.
Any suggestions that
you have for tooling,
any things that you've run into
when trying to develop for kind
of larger screen
platforms, I would
love to hear about it so
that we can tackle this.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]